well something I've been following
pretty closely on my show you can find
my show at Luke Beasley on YouTube is
the Bonkers uh hearings I know David's
been covering this too that Republicans
have been putting together in the House
of Representatives supposed to put
forward some argument in each of these
hearings and prove something and often
attack President Biden but so often the
word that I would say characterizes
these hearings from House Republicans is
backfire they keep
backfiring and today is yet another
example of this this is from earlier in
the week I didn't have a chance to cover
on my show or the Dave Hackman show so
I'm going to circle back to it
um now as we close the week and this had
to do with John Durham of course the
special counsel who investigated the
investigators in regard to the Russia uh
Pro Mueller investigation Crossfire
hurricane
and as was reported on by David by
myself it was a complete
while there are things in there that you
can find interesting and there are
notable parts of this Durham report
as a whole especially when you set it
next to what was promised from MaGa on
this Durham investigation it was a
nothing burger and it was supposed to
prove that there was this big conspiracy
at least in the eyes of Maga it was
supposed to prove that there's a
conspiracy to take down Trump by the FBI
and that's why the whole investigation
into Russian interference started in the
first place when in reality that's not
the case and that's not what Durham
uncovered and it mainly just uncovered
mistakes that were made in the
investigation fair enough make sure
those get corrected but clearly there
was good reason to investigate the
connection between the Trump campaign
and Russian government because of all
that we know is present there all the
connections that were uncovered but the
hearing most recently uh led by Jim
Jordan
didn't go too well where they brought
John Durham in front of the house
Judiciary Committee to
tout the success of this report I guess
and I'll show you a couple right Wingers
very angry about John Durham's
investigation and this hearing
specifically to give you a sense of how
this isn't going as they probably wanted
it to this is Steve Bannon first and
then we'll get into Democrats making
some great points right I mean yesterday
Jordan was pathetic he tried to make
Clark did he try to Saint Durham did he
try to make uh Durham Saint Durham
yeah absolutely I mean you know so
that's him saying Jim Jordan was
pathetic who was leading the hearing
that's not what you want to hear from a
right winger after one of these
political stunt hearings
um and then this is Matt Gates
questioning Durham and Matt Gates is
saying that Durham's investigation was a
failure but for the opposite reason
probably than you and I would think Matt
Gates thinks that Durham didn't uncover
what's there we realized he didn't
uncover what wasn't there
um but here's this Exchange
I think that's beyond the scope of
what's in the report it's literally the
scope of what your charging order is who
put it in motion we get after it was put
in motion the FBI did a bunch of wrong
and corrupt things totally understand
we're trying to deal with that but when
you are part of the cover-up Mr Durham
then it makes our job harder
yeah well if that's your thought I mean
there's no way of dissuading you from
that I can tell you that it's offensive
and that the people who worked on this
investigation have spent their lives
trying to protect people in this country
and pursue within the law
you tried two cases lost both of them
and then the One Plea guilty plea you
got Klein Smith Klein Smith is back to
practicing law in Washington D.C today
and that's beyond my control right but
but the the fact that you allowed that
plea to occur
right and and then the punishment was
insufficient the fact that you didn't
you didn't charge Andrew McCabe you
didn't convict the lion Democrats or the
lion Russians you didn't investigate
mifsud or the Mueller probe even though
as we sit here today in Black letter
that was your charge have you ever heard
of the Washington generals at the
Washington generals yes yeah and and
they're the team that basically gets
paid to show up and lose okay so again
Matt Gates is coming at a very different
perspective and I would say probably
rather dishonest one but he's
recognizing the failure of
um this Durham investigation because he
didn't really
uncover anything that wasn't already
covered by the inspector General's uh
investigation and the Mueller
investigation and I think any reasonable
person would say if you analyze the
facts of
both of those investigations and just
the whole situation kind of zoomed out
there was definitely reason to
investigate the connection and Russian
interference
and then we find that there isn't
evidence of trump directly coordinating
with the Russian government that's what
investigation are for and there's an
investigation of that or if there's not
proof of that uncovered in the
investigation then
um so be it and follow the facts and the
mistakes were made fair enough to
criticize but this idea that number one
there was nothing to be looked into by
the FBI and then by Mueller Lee in that
FBI investigation with all of the
convictions that Mueller got
and number two that this was a
conspiracy with the Democrats to take
down Trump
um rather
dishonest and then I have for you Adam
Schiff during this hearing
well your report
Mr Durham
doesn't dispute anything Mueller found
did it
no our object our aim was not to dispute
director Marlo I have the greatest
regard highest regard for director
Mueller he's a patriot the only
distinguishment between his
investigation and yours is he refused to
bring charges where he couldn't prove
guilty on a reasonable doubt and you did
and I've noted this in the past when
covering the Durham report but as you've
probably heard as well multiple times
Durham Pro two cases to trial and both
of them uh ended in acquittal and last
clip we'll look at just because both for
the sake of this hearing making sure the
attempt by the right to make the Durham
report something that it's not and also
just because it's representative of how
all of these political stunt hearings
aren't going well for uh the Republican
party I'll show you one more clip of Ted
Lou
now Mr Durham would like to ask you the
following simple yes or no questions
Trump's former campaign chairman Paul
manafort was convicted correct I'm sorry
could just repeat that Trump's former
campaign chairman Paul manafort was
convicted correct that's correct
policy advisor to the campaign George
Papadopoulos was convicted correct it's
correct Trump's former deputy campaign
manager Rick Gates was convicted correct
none in connection
all right
Mr Durham you can hold yourself out as
an objective Department of Justice
official or as a partisan hack and the
more that you try to spin the facts and
not answer my questions you sound like
the latter so I'm just asked this simply
Trump's former National Security advisor
Michael Flynn was convicted correct
that's correct
Trump's longtime advisor Roger Stone was
convicted correct I'm sorry missed the
last time long time advisor Roger Stone
was convicted correct correct
in contrast to multiple Trump Associates
were convicted
you brought two cases of jury trial
based on this investigation and you lost
both and so I don't actually know what
we're doing here because the author of
the Durham report concedes that the FBI
had enough information to
investigate and thank goodness the FBI
did because multiple Trump Associates
who committed crimes were held
accountable
we'll stop it there but
great points and
I really do wish
that the specifics of the claims could
be meaningfully broken down with a lot
of these people
um and imagine myself having a
one-on-one conversation with someone who
believes the FBI is being weaponized
against the conservatives and just go
one by one we went through yesterday and
likely we'll talk a little bit more
about it today the claim is being made
about Hunter Biden being treated with
kid clubs and if you walk through the
deal that he got it's very
uh expected very historically consistent
and uh same thing here where in any
extensive investigation can you find
problems and mistakes that were made a
hundred percent
but does that mean that it lives up to
the claim that was made about the
purpose of and the way the FBI went
about their investigation into the Trump
campaign the connection with Russia
Russian interference and all that no
and so a lot of the the layers as I
mentioned yesterday that are being laid
on to one another that build the
narrative in a lot of people's mind that
this is the reality the two-tier justice
system that targets conservatives helps
Democrats it's
um each layer if you discuss it
one-on-one it feels like a lot to them
but if you go one-on-one you realize
um it isn't what they think that it is
make sure you are uh subscribed to the
Dave Pacman show channel and my channel
on YouTube Luke Beasley I love a good
sauna after a workout after a stressful
or long day you get in the sauna to
unwind the blood vessels dilate your
heart rate goes up it can soothe muscles
and more now you can enjoy the same
effects from the comfort of your home
without a bunch of strangers walking
around which I personally am not big on
our sponsor Bond charge makes the
world's safest and most advanced sauna
blanket and it's tremendous I love
getting in there for reading or get a
little work done a little meditation
take a nap just gets you really relaxed
super easy to clean really compact
lightweight design simple to fold up and
put away when you're done with it and it
comes with a 12 month warranty if you
don't love it returns are really easy no
questions asked go to boncharge.com
Pacman use the code Pacman for 15 off
the link is down below